what is going on everybody and welcome
to a tech review of some security
cameras from real link so recently as
some of you guys know I moved and I was
in the market for some more security
cameras I was doing a bunch of research
I was just like completely blown away by
the number of options that are available
and trying to figure out which one to
get bla bla and I get asked to review
things all the time
but I don't think I've ever been asked
to review security cameras but I was by
this guy right as I'm researching them
and the timing was just too perfect so
here we are with a review now the camera
itself is an RLC 410 from rio link and
these are actually coming in a full
system so the system that i have here is
the rlk 8 - 410 b4 basically it's just
for the RL RL c 4 tens with a 2 terabyte
DVR which you don't necessarily have to
get those exact things so what are these
these rpoe or power over ethernet
cameras they are indoor/outdoor cameras
wherever you wanted to put them and they
also have infrared so you can see at
night so that actually you can see all
the little infrared LEDs there so that's
actually quite a few LEDs so let's
should get us some pretty good distance
and pretty good coverage the other
cameras that I have I want to say just
have like four LEDs and that actually
gets quite a bit of coverage so it'll be
interesting to see how good these are so
I've got four of these cameras to play
with here and so we need to talk about
what p OE or power over ethernet is and
i think you know really there's like
three main categories you could probably
make a four you could really make a
fourth for sure with cameras but you've
got like fully wired let's say so p OE
is fully wired right you've got the
camera has to be fully wired all the way
to the central base then you've got like
Wi-Fi type of cameras which just need to
be and these are generally called
wireless cameras these are going to be
they
still have wire for power but they
transmit data wirelessly and then you
have what are being called wire free
cameras which really just means
battery-powered now I'm not the biggest
fan of battery-powered cameras you know
the whole the way they work first of all
is offsetting batteries but they're not
always recording they only record events
like motion detected events or passive
IR detected events which I'm just not
the biggest fan of but they have their
various use cases for sure but I'm more
after something that's just recording
24/7 so then that pretty much throws me
into the category of the wireless or
Wi-Fi cameras versus fully wired now I
already have wireless cameras those are
really nice for when you you you have
like a good distance from your main base
unit but you're close to a plug that you
could plug in empower them so they have
their use but the problem is they still
lose their signal from time to time I
mean like just like the wind blowing can
make the signal go away
and so that's kind of annoying so with p
OE you just have high fidelity like it's
gonna work or any fully wired camera you
can have a little more trust in faith in
the system 99% of what I use cameras for
is like bing-bong the doorbell rings I
just want to I always want to look right
over to my monitor and see what's going
on so and yes I know that they have all
kinds of things that you can just like
put up there the problem is then you
gotta like open up your phone or
whatever and I just I want to literally
be able to just look instantly and get
my answer
so anyways not to say there's not places
for like the battery powered stuff or
you know any other options out there it
just kind of depends so in my case I've
got a garage that is unfinished so
there's no insulation on the walls and
there's really just plywood for the
ceilings but being able to run the cords
will be super super simple here also the
best deterrents there could possibly be
so in here we got basically four of
these I think they're about 25 feet but
don't quote me on that we got four
cameras DVR mouse for the DVR and
somewhere in there should be like an
HDMI cable and all that so now what I'm
going to do is going to go ahead and
pull away all this stuff and start
plugging it in it doesn't come that
messy by the way I'd already opened it
up so far setting up super simple just
plug and play
[Music]
this is one of the best tools ever made
on the camera there's like three a two
millimeter allen screws the each camera
comes with a supplied two millimeter
allen wrench you can turn all those to
adjust rotation and all that so to
adjust the camera all I did was I just
used the real link app on my phone and
then I you know adjusted the camera to
exactly where I wanted it angle wise and
all that so that was actually super darn
simple too to get everything set up now
did mention before that you could in
theory you know you you could use a POA
camera and not actually wire it all the
way to a central unit and so this
picture is just a quick example of a way
that I tested to make sure that I was
correct there and sure enough if you
wanted to you could have a POS which so
in this case I'm just using a Netgear
POS which connected to a Google Wi-Fi
router and then obviously power the
switch and then plug the camera into it
and that works totally fine
interestingly enough if it's on the same
network as the NVR the NVR actually
picks it up and you could record
straight to the NVR but you can also do
all the other things that you can do so
this is just an image of the night shot
from the app on my phone the app again
super super simple to set up you just
have to log in that's it took me like I
don't know a minute to get everything
set up so that was really impressive
this is of the backyard the infrared it
might be kind of hard to tell but that's
actually a pretty good distance there so
the distance from where I'm showing this
image now and again this image is an
image off of my phone and I didn't
realize it at the time but you can
actually set the quality to be full
quality so this is a degraded quality in
the name of one not using up a bunch of
you know phone data but also to stream
it very very smoothly but when it
records it records in high definition
anyways the distance there to the door
is about 73 feet I measured it and then
to the corner there is 85 feet so if
everything was in your favor you might
get the the up to 100 foot but this is
actually pretty darn good this is much
better than my other infrared cameras
so then I've moved it a little bit and
just to show you so the leaves there
that are you know real bright those are
25 feet away so that's that's pretty
good because I call you know I turn off
all the lights and all that most of the
time you see infrared you know examples
of IR cameras they generally have a
light source that is at least aiding
them and in this case there was no light
source even the reflection that you see
there that's the infrared so anyways I'm
pretty impressed and finally onto the
real link software if the phone app was
any indication it's no surprise that the
desktop app is just as simple to use has
quite a bit more features though so
first of all you can obviously set up
you know all kinds of different you know
organizations of the cameras that you
want to go with also the well first of
all I'm only showing two cameras thought
it was kind of stupid to show like all
of the cameras so anyway just the two
and the reason why this is getting
duplicated interestingly enough is B
this is the camera that I'd showed just
moments ago with that's connected only
via the Google mesh networking the
Google Wi-Fi router so that's pretty
cool it's it's it's being it's being
shown twice because it's being picked up
as a net like a camera on the network
but also the NVR is picking it up
because it's on the same network I
didn't think that would happen I thought
you would have to wire the camera to the
NVR if you wanted to record on to it
that's not the case so that's pretty
cool so anyways you can change the
layout all that you can double click on
one of them and yeah so now you've got
basically like the full resolution of
that camera it looks pretty good and you
can do all kinds of stuff so first of
all we could go into the settings for
the actual desktop itself we could set
up various rules and stuff for
downloading and capturing things like
from your cameras to your local machine
I wouldn't recommend it unless you've
got giant hard drives though but then
you can also set up the NVR itself by
clicking on the Settings here and then
again same things you can do various
schedules so right now this is just a
24/7 schedule but I could you know knock
out a block here or something like that
if I wanted to or I could say you know
what in this time range I actually
record but only if you see motion or
something like that you can do so that's
pretty cool and again super intuitive
just to set that up and get it
structured how you want also besides the
recording to your PC you also can
actually record the cameras to FTP so if
you're really security conscious or
you're really worried that you're gonna
get broken into or whatever and you want
to save the evidence that's the best way
to do it a lot of times if they're gonna
break in they're gonna want to find out
where it's getting recorded to but if
it's going to FTP good luck
so anyways also you can go to playback
you can playback historically and if
you're recording on motion or there's
motion detected you could very quickly
find that otherwise like I'll go to the
NVR I'll choose channel two and I can
see down here it's kind of in the way
but I can see down here all the dates
that there is something so this has only
been connected well this has been
connected as of yesterday to the
specific spot so what we could do is I
could just go over here all the other
time it's just a micro I was headed in
my garage and we can hit play here oh I
probably need to bring no it's there
okay
so again you can see the night vision
but it's getting a lot of reflection
both from the porch light here but then
also here so as far as night vision I'd
probably want to like angle it maybe
away from the tree or something like
that or maybe cut away some more of
these leaves so we're not getting that
reflection back to the camera
anyway that's good let's try to find
some daylight here there we go beautiful
amazing okay so the next thing is like
let's say oh I see something or I want
to download it or whatever you can just
come up here and hit this download and
then basically you can download it in
like our chunks you can download
multiple chunks if you wanted or all the
chunks if you want it but it's basically
separated in the little hour chunks for
you hit download and it'll go to your
download directory so anyways I believe
that covers everything with the cameras
overall I'm super impressed this was one
of the easiest ones to set up I was a
little worried with you know having to
run the wires but again you could use a
switch but also a real link does produce
Wi-Fi camera so if that's what you're
really going after then use it although
I would say if you do use Google Wi-Fi
you know how good it is so
I would probably rather use that than
the Wi-Fi camera I haven't used theirs
but the other Wi-Fi cameras I have I
don't like them as much because they
lose signal fairly frequently especially
because it's going through like brick
walls and many other walls to get to a
central unit anyway that's it I'm super
impressed I really like these cameras if
you're looking for you know POA cameras
I would HIGHLY highly recommend these if
you have any questions comments whatever
on the cameras feel free to leave them
below otherwise I will see you guys next
time